all right i need your help figuring
something out is this
a political story or a mental health
story that i am going to be talking
about right now and what i mean
is a pro-trump attorney lynn wood
who was involved in trying to overturn
the 2020 election results he spoke at
some length at an event in south
carolina on tuesday
and claimed that donald trump is still
the president donald trump is still in
control of the
military could authorize a nuclear
first strike by the military if he
wanted to
so that's where the question comes from
is this a political story
or is it a mental health story and
lynnwood simply needs impatient
treatment i'm not being facetious
i'm not playing coy with mental health
it's just not clear to me
what kind of a story this is so let's
just jump into the video
donald j trump has never conceded
because he won the election so be cool
it's all gonna be good at that
donald j trump is still the guy the
military will call
for the code if they need a first strike
joe biden is not pressing the united
can't states stop it this is driving me
crazy
so that's already like a treasure trove
of gold
uh if the military needed a first strike
they'd call
trump for the code and by that i assume
he means a nuclear first strike the
scenario that linwood is laying out is
the military wants to strike someone
with a nuke
they go to joe biden and say sir we need
the codes
and biden says no we're not launching a
nuke so the military says let's call
trump at mar-a-lago he'll give us the
code
sir give us the code biden won't here it
is have it
boom a nuke is launched it's a
delusional scenario i mean truly
let's watch a little bit more of this
somebody do something well you gotta
remember this man
i'm gonna tell you what i think because
listen i think they're gonna fix this
election in a month
right but we would have gone right back
into the same
swamp in the same mess and nothing would
have really been fixed
so remember this isn't about trump and
this isn't about flesh this is about god
this is about powers and principalities
god's getting ready to clean up this
world
and he's got a lot of plenty of them to
do in america so
you don't want trump to come back yet
because
some things are going to have to happen
he's going to enjoy where
the bad stuff happened he goes whoa i
don't like that biden administration
it's not going to be on trump's watch
but trump is
watching so now he puts out this other
idea
we could have overturned the election
with the results in one month
but then if trump came back in it would
have been more swamped because we
haven't fixed the swamp yet this isn't
about trump it's about these other
things so trump will come back in time
when it makes more sense for donald
trump to be back but for now trump is
watching
and he's ready to do the military strike
because he still controls the nuclear
codes
those are some big claims being made
and none of them have even the slightest
connection to reality
uh let's listen to the last bit here
which it might be the craziest part of
all of it
i believe my own personal belief is that
he signed the insurrection act
nobody knows he's not going to tell
anybody i think the military is prepared
to act if we have a foreign threat or an
internal threat that
can't be held by the police and the
national guard and we're going to allow
that to be what appears to be continuity
of government it's going to be painful
about some things where you're learning
about what you're good at
if you've really gotten by because he's
cleaning things up so i know it's tough
to hear lynn wood
because of all the constant coughing in
the room my guess is that's maybe a not
heavily vaccinated crowd
but he said there he thinks that trump
actually signed the insurrection act in
private
and the military knows that donald trump
still is actually in control of the
military
which is out of this world bonkers i
mean just
completely divorced from any even
possible reality
and seriously this stuff has an impact
it's not just linwood people believe
this stuff
there are right now or at least a couple
days ago there were people walking
around
filling plastic shopping bags with
liquid gasoline
and those some of those same people
refuse to take a vaccine that is safe
and can end the pandemic of course
there are people who hear this and they
believe it and they act accordingly
um and uh you know the
the incredible um kind of it's not
really a
it's a conflict i guess i would call it
is that on the one hand
if you ask these folks how do you feel
about what joe biden is doing while in
office they'll say it's terrible
joe biden is doing all of these horrible
things but then at the same time
some of them still believe that donald
trump is really in power
uh pulling all the strings and
controlling everything so well so how is
joe biden even able to do anything if
donald trump is actually still in power
don't even try don't even try it will
merely be an exercise in frustration
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like
any delicious coffee but it's really
easy on my stomach doesn't give me any
jittery feeling or a midday crash and
they have over
20 000 five star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get 100 percent
of your money back because they stand
behind their product
you've got nothing to lose by giving it
a try four sigmatic is giving my
audience up to forty percent
off and free shipping when you go to
four sigmatic dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video